that's right it's time for griezmann
it's your lazy susan of news packed with
all those good news condiments and with
me at the desk is my little chalula
yeah everybody
i
picked cholula because it was such a
sweet name it is my favorite of the hot
sauces
you know i love a sauce that's why i go
buy sauce matthews
i love dipping i do too and um i'm
really excited i found this story
it's a holiday uh story that is headed
for hollywood
all right um back in 2016 a grandma
named wanda
meant to text her grandson to invite him
to thanksgiving but she texted a young
man named jamal by mistake they were
total strangers jamal came over anyway
to thanksgiving
and he's been coming over every
thanksgiving since oh we love this and
the verge is reporting netflix
is turning their accidental friendship
into a movie called the thanksgiving
text it's very literal yeah
jamal and wanda hopes it inspires people
to reach out and make connections that
they might not make usually make here's
what i say let's just be more open to
when we get the wrong number
because this is my whole fantasy about
wrong numbers can lead to things the
wrong number can sometimes be the right
person if you just pick up right
well you know people are like so just
dismissive sometimes yeah i don't want
to be that way you are so the person who
would become best friends with the
person who called you accidentally i i i
did send a video that i meant to send to
cameron diaz and it was me getting
dressed in the closet there was it was
all above the shoulders i'm no idiot
but you know of course i'm doing a towel
dance and i'm just being silly you can't
see anything but i sent it to a 16 year
old boy named matthew
so
that and he literally said he's like i'm
so sorry but i'll never show anyone this
video
oh well shout out to matthew thanks
matthew
all right hey you know we're celebrating
west side story all week long it's our
friday
[Applause]
yes and we've got a little spicy story
about the anita who started it all oscar
winner rita moreno people reports rita
recently admitted that when she found
out that marlon brando was cheating on
her way back in the day they were dating
you know what she did to get get back at
him make him jealous well she dated
elvis
yeah that's what you do she went on a
couple dates but she said elvis was
sweet but he was a hunk a hunk of boring
love
and then when marlon brando found out
about elvis well he went crazy he like
threw chairs he was furious oh yeah and
rita said quote it was wonderful
yeah brando elvis oh rita
and you know you know she's got sort of
oscar buzz going on right now which has
a really interesting twist to it tell us
about it she's playing valentina in the
new west side story and she's the only
ever the latina ever to win an acting
oscar if you can believe that i cannot
believe that
and with all this buzz
for the new west side story if she wins
again she'll be the first person to win
twice for the same movie and she'd break
katherine hepburn's record for the
longest time between winning an oscar
katherine hepburn went 48 years between
oscars this would be 60 years since
sherida mourinho won her first event and
ariana dubose who will be on the show
this week who is um the new anita
if she doesn't win the academy award for
this performance which would also make
oscar history for somebody winning you
know an oscar for the same role
she's a revelation so
um next up um speaking of movies sony is
making a new movie about hollywood's
greatest dancer of all time
the elegant the effortless the
magnanimous fred astaire wow and
hollywood reporter reports that they
have picked the man to bring him to life
it is none other than british actor tom
holland come
[Applause]
you know him as spider-man but he
started his career dancing in billy
elliot in london's west end
and um amazon's also making their own
fred and ginger movie starring jamie
bell who was originally billy elliot in
the film and margaret quality who is
literally one of my favorite human
beings on the planet andy mcdowell's
daughter a total revelation um and you
know what i'm excited about also i love
to review things here on the show and
somebody called into the show and gave
us the idea of doing drew's reviews
because we rhymed my name with
everything
and i'm excited to do one let's do it
it's drew's reviews okay come on
um okay it's a holiday tool to slice
your gift wrapping time in half behold
the little elf watch out scissors
you're going back in the drawer the sun
reports this tool is going viral and
they say it gives you a quick easy and
straight cut on your wrapping paper oh
my god look at look at it here already
oh hi
that was exciting how satisfying i think
it would be a real game changer
look at that at first i wasn't sure
about it now i'm like obsessed with it
hold on i'm in in
all right how many stars out of five
rossi i'm gonna give this i'm gonna give
this four stars out of five because look
yeah
that's so satisfying it's under six
dollars and i'm totally getting what
this this gets a five out of five oh hey
that's a very rare five out of five if
there's something you'd like us to try
just let us know on social media because
you know drew's reviews is all about you
guys wanting to try stuff too so let's
do it together
[Music]
you